[Aplausos]
imagina a caminhar pelas ruas e de
repente ouvimos vozes vindo por água nos
solos e cuidados
infelizmente não tem chapa a cidade
poderá ajudá-las mundo das plantas
vocês estão aqui curiosas o deixa me
lembrar vos o que são plantas plantas
são seres vivos orgânicos que nascem
crescem reproduzem fim mordem a
diferença ou que distingue as plantas de
nós homens e os animais é que elas para
se moverem do lado para o outro não
fazia isso de forma voluntária precisam
de ajuda e quando falo de plantas elas
podem ser aquáticas e terrestres e
aéreas
e outra coisa é que eu descobrir que
afinal as plantas já existem bem mesmo a
dia da nossa existência e elas são
responsáveis pela vida na terra ela já
oferecemos combustível oxigênio
alimentos e medicamentos
isso tudo desde muito cedo e vou pensar
o que o curso fazer para que as plantas
continue a existir e 20 afinal era muito
difícil seria eu a tentar
já a plantar e alguma coisa disse 'não
ana faz alguma coisa começa a dona de
estágio e eu disse eu vou ser a voz que
as representa
vou começar de pequenino e assim comecei
a reabilitar criar e manter jalich então
já plantei muitas árvores quando falo de
plantas falo de árvores arbustos toda a
vida vegetal
então a primeira coisa com a lei que as
mulheres se preocupam muito dinheiro
preciso aparar as contas do meu cabelo
para dar mais vida e isso também existe
no mundo das plantas elas precisam ser
podadas para dar mais vida então vou
compartilhar com vocês
quatro formas de fazer uma roda primeiro
vocês devem organizar materiais super
afiadas bem afiados e extremidades deve
usar equipamentos de figurar higiene e
segurança luvas óculos
depois devem identificar que podem que
eu quero fazer é para que a uma boa
informação aquela que os jardineiros de
findar curvas
as plantas existe uma boda de ativação
de produção onde tiramos alguns galhos
para fazer com que a seiva vá pra
congelamos que a gente quer que dêem
frutos maiores ou flores de histórias ea
uma poda que nós fazemos para reabilitar
uma planta que está livre tratada doente
e aí tá bom vamos toda a planta para dar
vida para fazer com que os raios do sol
e metem
o país quando uma uma planta as raízes
de uma planta invadem um edifício vocês
já viram então deve se fazer uma poda
para evitar 30 anos nesse processo todo
descobri também que havia alguma
semelhança entre nós e vocês sempre que
precisarem fazer alguma transformação
nos vossos cabelos
olhem os lados e procure simone uma
planta por socorro
rodado entre as plantas são as mulheres
constantemente precisa hidratar saber me
tratar as unhas de hidratar apenas as
plantas também precisam disso precisam
de água e sol sempre tiveram uma planta
a china falou que teve uma orquídea
ficar gastar boa iluminação adequada
então procurem saber no youtube com uma
amiga ou procurem saber comigo mesma o
link qual é o ambiente adequado para
aquela planta como equívoco por água ea
última é preciso amor
as plantas precisam também de cuidados
de saúde às pragas como falou que
aparecem as pragas aparecem quando há
alguma alguma mudança de clima então faz
com que apareçam formei das ilhas e
provocam algumas doenças em espécies de
planta
então vocês sempre que tiverem alguma
coisa pra cuidar
saúde por favor hoje é o vosso redor e
vejam se não há nenhuma planta ali com
alguma praga ea última coisa eo amor
todos nós queremos nuda basta o amorim
foi quem lhe paciência empatia compaixão
perdão e as plantas oferece isso e muito
mais
quero desafiar vocês hoje não hoje à
tarde e amanhã amanhã você identifique
uma planta e cuidem dela desde o
princípio e aprendam a linguagem dela
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]